le malaise sensation pénible mal
localisée à troubles physiologiques
brusque défaillance des forces physiques
pour aller jusqu'à l'évanouissement est
un sentiment de troubles de gênes
d'inquiétude de tension bienvenue dans
essayer de ne pas être mal à l'aise
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur mal estimé dans
la première vidéo qu'on avait fait de ce
genre ont été charles un compte twitter
qui en fait
reprenez les vidéos deux malaises tv
vilain garçon alors on va pas garder les
52 km es18 j'ai fait une petite
présélection me basant sur le titre et
sur la durée de la vidéo c'est parti
nous ne devons pas rire être mal à
l'aise les deux les deux voies la double
giles qui suit à faire
[Musique]
ah non ça varie non ça va arriver
non ça va arriver non plus mais qu un
pâton prendre à la mecque réfléchi
qu'est ce qui te parle
non non
[Applaudissements]
là
télé en pls met-elle en bois laisse mes
choix tard de sécurité mais taylor benes
mon gars le cauchemar diouf mais ce qui
est extraordinaire dans l'histoire c'est
que le mec à la sono et lorsqu'en même
du bruno mars
[Applaudissements]
je suis hyper désolé pour ce mec il dit
quand un stagiaire crois qu'un
journaliste lui parle sans le bon vin ça
les peintures de cartes qui ont acheté
des couches sur la dernière semaine
on peut très bien pour ça oui et qu'est
ce qui sort du côté des lignes de
chaînettes des couches sur la dernière
semaine
on peut très bien sûr ça oui et qu'est
ce qui sort du côté des lignes de
chiffres
ça ne m'est pas halal sbg presque rigaud
l'école où était pas l'oreille a fait
gagner là
c'est dur de boire ptdr de lol mariage
sont bourrés déjà ça marche forcée nec
jusqu'au bout ils ont du mal au nom au
nom mais ils sont stressés c'est leur
mariage non c'est normal c'est normal
tranquille
gros bide à l'hélium en boîte des lieux
mon bois de j'ai un problème j'ai trouvé
le même clou de la soirée moteur alors
demain ça va
la famille soirée avec elle ça déchire
où il est
attention attention
moi j'ai eu
ok pas génial mais bon sympa au la
bâtarde que tu es pour juger des mecs
bourrés qui s'amuse avec de l'hélium et
j'ai pas ça parce que je sais pas
un robot qui détecte les mouches sur un
cadavre à samedi un truc ça alors une
question oui on vous donne le micro
monsieur on donne sur le savoir ce qu'il
est je vous suis sûr qu'elle a regretté
cette décision déjà d'entrée de jeu sur
l'île du savoir ce qu'il a été mis au
point un robot qui détecte une mouche
qui a été sur un cadavre en campagne et
qui rentre dans les maisons qui va sur
du pain ou du beurre elle est élevée
tu parles d'un robot qui était que les
mouches à merde qui ensuite vont sur du
pain est la même tout ce qu'elle dit je
vois pas où est d'interlocuteur a étiré
la poignée rouge laqué autodétruit le
micro je sais pas qui soient détectés le
vert si les scellés pas contaminés on
n'entend plus parler que les gens ils
peuvent se nous arrêtent de combler le
malaise en disant que tu ne vois pas ton
interlocuteur tout le monde se rend
compte de la supercherie parce qu'il ya
eu il ya eu un problème d'âge pas
rigoler je passe à côté pas dans mes
skis c'est extraordinaire ce qu'elle a
dit désolé donc il faut un contre au
débat c'est comme en soirée théâtre avec
ici donc il faut une contre soirée là où
ils font un contre au débat et le débat
c'est juste où est le mec qui parle
j'avoue c'est pas con c'est mr moyen de
zapper complètement ce que le mcddi qui
est en train de parler quand qu'on ait
l'air de vous répondre
il assume alors non je sais ce que tout
ce que je peux vous dire c'est qu'il est
un robot je crois il me semble qu'il est
japonais mais j'en suis pas sûr que tous
leurs beaux messieurs voyez on pourrait
philosopher pendant très longtemps sur
comment nous arrive certaines remarques
et notamment généré une conception de ma
vie avoir notamment et donc
comment dire sur la wii j'avais discuté
en fait j'avais leur étant libristes
demain mais non mais alors qu à ces deux
mecs vont se retrouver dans la même
salle au même endroit ce possible donc
j'ai posé une question ça non j'ai fait
une remarque j'ai pas vu le mac à droite
qui mobilise toutes les ressources de
son corps pour essayer de comprendre ce
que ce gars dit non ils ont créé un
robot libre 1re libre bondi droit mais
c'est pas de droit qu'il faut dire
effectivement et donc c'est dur je peux
pas résister et donc j'ai comme réponse
à ça y est c'est beau il exaspéré il a
lâché la tous mobilisés pendant 20
secondes puis l'on pouvait plus il ya
une question la question c'est par
rapport à louis saez pouvez vous me
parler turgot au les chutes à l'ewf je
kiffe ce mec on va enchaîner quand même
attendez on peut pas on peut pas vous
entendre sans micro monsieur voilà
est-ce qu'il a été mis au point un robot
qui détecte le la bei qui a été
contaminée de pesticides qui quand la
voie au sol elle peut plus voler alors
donc ça veut dire quelque chose c'est un
signe pour l'instant ça n'existe dans ce
corps pris naissance de l'état où il a
vu là il a ramené comme ça c'était dur
c'était très dur
le bide une fan de pokémon du coup il y
aura un petit gage alors toi tu vas
devoir limiter à cri d'un pokémon ce que
tu veux dans les poses et à enlever donc
ça m'a épuisé je pourrai plus jamais un
sérum concentré autant pour éviter de
faire un faux que je dorme forme comme
le mec au début de la vidéo je suis sur
lui arrive est pareil elle avait déjà
fait un bide il a tout donné pour paris
il s'est endormi
bonjour qu'est ce que c'est que ça je
vois m nous fait sketch sur quelque
chose où tu te lâche un peu parce que là
j'ai l'impression que y'a pas quoi ta
libre avant de ballard s'est coincé t'as
pas le sourire tape à l'oeil qui pétille
et à rien tu te tournes et quand tu te
retournes on veut voir quelque chose qui
bouge quelque chose qui met la pêche
dans leur registre que tu veux mais on
va voir quelque chose qui déménage
allez vas-y un bon genre vous allez bien
vous n'avez pas l'air d'aller bien là on
répondait pas pourquoi il faut de l'air
une fois dollar il faut là
c'est bon ça aujourd'hui c'était moi on
a droit d'en rigoler mais il faut pas
aller a reçus et les gens n'ont plus un
jeu qui en a qui désirent s'amuser à
retrouver les gens à les ai reçus la
smoke et smoke et tous les jours ça ça
rien pas le faire déjà ce qu'on fait là
c'est un peu limite je suis sûr que sur
un élève pour la fecq mika y ait eu
plein etc
j'ai franchement fait un bisou au moment
où je me retrouvais dans une de ses
vidéos horrible à la semaine prochaine
et inversait le regarder je vais rire
pour 10 minutes à une fois que j'aurai
dans celles où trop besoin d'évacuer
effectué je vous dis allez retirer du
projet à savoir garder durant tout le
monde